So just this morning, I was reading an article about a biblical document
or an allegedly biblical document that was about 1
,500 to 2,000 years old. And this document is called the Epistle of
Barnabas. Now, the article said that this epistle claimed that Jesus never
actually resurrected. In fact, Jesus was just simply a prophet that Jesus ascended
to heaven without dying. And that Judas Iscariot was actually crucified in Jesus's
place. Now, if you've ever read this book, then you know none of those things are in
this book the way I've just described them.
But here is an article that says that this is true and like, oh, this is this
astounding new information that we have about Jesus.
But as Christians, we know that this book, a Bible, is what tells
us the truth of Christianity. Which kind of raises an interesting question.
How do I know this document is true?
And that's what this whole series of unit or this whole unit is about.
All these lessons are going to walk you through how we know the Bible is true, how
we know that it's accurate, how we know that it's reliable and authoritative.
See, the problem is that often what we do is we get stuck into this loop where we
ask the question of how do I know that the Bible is true?
Okay, well
then we say, well that's because the Bible says so.
Well how do I know that the Bible says so?
Well because I know the Bible is true and we just keep going in a circle over and
over and over again and we never actually have anything exterior that helps us
understand whether or not the Bible is actually true.
We throw in there a little bit of, well it's the inspired, I can't
write, inspired Word of God.
And therefore it must be true and it must be because the Bible says so, because it's
the inspired Word of God, because we know it's true and we go on and on that way.
How do I know beyond all of those things that this is true?
How do I know that it's authoritative?
How do I know that what's in these pages are actually going to teach me on how
to live the life that God has designed for me.
And that's what students need to know, and that's what we're going to explore.
In this first week, we're going to talk about texts.
And it is this text, specifically the New Testament, is the New Testament text.
Now last week, we ended talking about Jesus, and all that Jesus said, and
all that Jesus claimed to be in the resurrection, all this stuff about Jesus.
How do I know that what's in here about Jesus in the New Testament is
accurate? Well, what's fascinating about that is that we have what's
called an autograph and
a manuscript.
Now, an autograph is an original copy, okay?
An autograph is as if I actually gave my autograph, my signature.
It's original to me. I wrote it and only I can write it.
That's essentially what we're talking about when we say an autograph.
When we talk about texts from antiquity, the ancient texts, those biblical times and
earlier and all around that era, we have no autographs.
We have nothing originally written by anybody in their physical hand.
Okay, but what we do have is manuscripts, copies.
Sometimes there are copies of a copy of a copy that isn't entirely possible.
So the question we have to answer in this first lesson is do we have enough
manuscripts and do we have enough manuscripts that are accurate across
all of the copies to say that what's in here, in my hand, is
an accurate representation
of what Paul wrote, what Jesus said, what Peter wrote, and what actually
happened during the days of Jesus.
So to start this process, we ask students in the introduction activity to look
up a legal document that proves their existence.
So think about you have a birth certificate you have a driver's license
right you can't get on an airplane without a driver's license or a passport uh you
often asked for your Social Security card anytime your identity is checked for a job
or that kind of thing right so you have to have some kind of proof of your existence
that you are who you say you are so we have these legal binding documents
that are proof of something so we want students to start to see that there are
documents out there even today that have this kind of power.
All right, so I want you to think about your students' textbooks in school,
especially the ones that talk about ancient literature.
So think of like a world history textbook that's going to talk about the details of
the ancient Roman Empire, Alexander the Great, and some of the great armies and the
movement of barbarian tribes, those kinds of things that sort of
help shape the history of the modern world.
All the things that your students learn and really consider to be actual fact,
right? So all of those things are derived from historical texts
and derived from different things that give us clues into understanding
what happened in history. So for instance, you have things like
natural history by
a historian named Pliny. Now this guy was a Roman historian and most of what he
wrote about had to do with agricultural and business and economics and those kinds
of things but it gives us great insight into what Rome was like and how to
understand the Roman Empire and some of the insights that we have into their world
and their technology as an ancient culture, all right?
So we have not a ton of copies, okay?
So estimate we have roughly 100 or so, maybe less, maybe more
of something like that. Now those are copies over a copy, over a copy,
different languages sometimes are scattered throughout different places, those kinds
of things. Now, how much of the New Testament do we have?
How much of the actual New Testament?
Now this isn't full Bibles. I don't want you thinking like this is a bunch of actual
full Bible copies. Sometimes they're just little pieces, little fragments, little
things that we've got to place together.
Sometimes they're full books. Sometimes they're multiple books together.
But oftentimes these are scattered all throughout the region from the east to the
West, and they're found in all kinds of different places or times.
So we have, if you put all of that together, roughly in excess
of 6,000 copies of just
the New Testament.
Now, if you put a whole bunch of other things together, you're talking in excess of
20,000 different copies.
That's a lot of copies.
Now, what happens if you say, well, how accurate are these copies?
Because that's going to help understand how accurate this is.
If you put all the copies together, everything across the board is in
excess of 95% the same. And that 3-5%
is like words like the and a and things that may have been missing
or may have taken out. But none of it affects theology.
Now, that's pretty astounding. And in your leader guide, we've given
you resources to find out some more detailed and exact numbers.
I would encourage you to check those out.
Josh McDowell has actually just updated some of those numbers.
And some of these have even gotten better and better over the last couple of years.
So I would encourage you to check those out and share those numbers with your
students. Because it's almost mind-bending to think that the New Testament
as it is here is actually more reliable and more
historical
than some of the stuff that's in the textbooks that your students are reading and
learning in school as fact. Now, I'm not saying those aren't fact, but how much more
is the New Testament reliable than some of the world history books that we have in
schools? See, it's a lot more reliable.
This is huge right so I do want to make one comment about the misconception and
illumination because what we've done here is slightly different than what we've done
in the past before the misconception was often a verse or a comment that was
misunderstood
frequently by students and we wanted to point them in a direction that corrects them
but also illuminates their understanding further this year what we did is we wanted
to pull out some information from some other authors, some notable atheists and some
people that don't agree with what Christianity teaches.
So you'll notice very specifically this week we have Bart Ehrman is a
New Testament critic, agnostic probably, was a
Christian, understands the Bible very very well but writes specifically against
what the Bible teaches and that the Bible is not accurate and he says that we
have only error-ridden copies and the vast majority of these are centuries removed
from the originals and different from them evidently in thousands of ways.
Well, what's fascinating about that is that Bart Ehrman says that, but what we just
talked about here clearly contradicts.
So it's important for you to bring this up specifically so that you can help your
students navigate some of these things because these are not obscure authors and
people that you never hear of. These are mainstream people in the media that are on
TV sometimes that are often featured during like National Geographic and Discovery
Channel kinds of specials where your students may come across them in the future.
And we want you to be aware so you can help make them aware to be able to say, well,
you know what? Look at these kinds of comments critically so that they understand
that just because someone like this says this that doesn't necessarily make that
true. And they want to make sure that they dive into the actual evidence.
If you read on what Bart Ehrman says, super smart guy but doesn't really back
comments like this up with a whole bunch of evidence.
One resource that I do want to point out is Jonathan Morrow wrote an excellent book
called Questioning the Bible 11 Major Challenges to the Bible's Authority and it's
our suggested resource inside The Leader's Guide.
So I would suggest that you pick that up yourself but that book is designed
specifically to speak to your students so if your students have questions
about this topic specifically or they're just stuck and you need to move on or
they just want to know more encourage them or maybe even just buy it for them get
this book and have them read through it and then set up a different discussion on
that book specifically and it'll be a tremendous resource for them so if we're
getting what we believe from the Bible, then we better be sure what the Bible says
is saying it accurately.
And although it may seem we have thousands of different kinds of translations and we
have so many copies, the Bible is the best-selling book in the history of the world.
It's been copied so many times over and over and over and over again.
And there are lots of people that are trying to discredit it.
But when you continue to look at the evidence, the Bible continues to
prove itself as something that has been transmitted over the course of
history accurately and reliably to what was actually
recorded originally.
So what Paul, so you can be confident and you can remind your students as you sit in
a small group and encourage them and help them understand that what Paul wrote and
what Jesus said is actually what Paul wrote and what Jesus said.
Now that has incredible consequences, right?
Either we listen to what Paul says and what Jesus says and what Peter says and what
went on and the gospel and the Old Testament and all that's going on in here or we
don't but we can't assume that this isn't accurate
so as you're getting into your small groups talk with your students about
okay so now that they understand that there's a reliability to this and we're going
to get even more into it in the next couple of weeks here but start to poke a little
bit at them and say you know well what's this going to mean down the road what's
this going to mean today? What's this going to mean tomorrow and next week and the
next couple of weeks? The more you discover about the importance of this book, what
is that going to mean for your life?
Because the more you know about this, the less you can ignore it.